it's reported at least 44 trans people
were murdered in 2020 alone
and despite your fears you say you feel
a deep responsibility to share your
truth
why
well you know so much of the privilege i
have
the ability to uh be here
sitting here right now is really because
of so many trans women of color who
have consistently put their lives on the
line throughout history
you know when we think of marsha p
johnson
or miss major
i'm grateful to have the access to the
resources i've
i've had because i don't know what would
have happened if i didn't
and so many people in this community
like i said don't have access to health
care already and then you have now in
states them trying to ban gender
affirming health care for
transgender youth and i guess
i don't know how to really say it other
than it just feels
more important than feeling scared in
moments it feels more important than
if i have an overwhelming day
it to me s really simply feels like
absolutely the right thing to do
who or what force helped you
to move through the fear who did you
lean on or what did you
lean on to help you move through the
fear
i'm surrounded by really incredible
people
who i work with and just fully support
me
friends who you know fully support me
and are there for me
and um and again being inspired by
so many people who have a lot more
courage than i do and
that you know that love and support and
encouragement was your mom was your mom
a big source of support
yeah i mean i i think as i talked in the
time article
uh obviously in my childhood things were
you know a bit different but my mom
can't be
you know couldn't be more supportive and
such an advocate for the lgbtq plus
community
so thrilled for me and that i'm in this
place in my life
you